jason momoa and lisa bonay's
relationship is officially over and now
a source is telling e.t why the two
actors decided to call it quits after 16
years together having a strong woman
standing by your side i mean we support
each other and all the arts and what our
endeavors are so it seems lisa and jason
were struggling in their relationship
for some time our source explaining
quote when jason was away filming
aquaman 2 their differences and issues
were heightened he was gone for a while
and it definitely put additional stress
on their relationship and although the
two are going their separate ways the
source adds quote they still have love
for each other and respect one another
it's beautiful to go through so many
different
challenges in our lives and have a
partner that loves you through all of it
so jason announced the news of their
separation on instagram last wednesday
but has since deleted the post here's
the joint statement the aquaman star
shared on the couple's behalf which
reads in part quote we share our family
news that we are parting ways in
marriage he goes on to say the love
between us carries on evolving in ways
that wishes to be known and lived we
free each other to be who we are
learning to become jason adds our
devotion unwavering to this sacred life
and our children teaching our children
what's possible living the prayer may
love prevail j and l jason and lisa have
been together since 2005 but the pair
officially tied the knot in october
2017. what's been the best thing about
being married and making it official
next level
next level they share two children
together daughter lola and son nicoa
wolfe jason is also the stepfather to
actress zoe kravitz lisa's daughter with
ex-husband lenny kravitz the justice
league star has always supported zoe in
her career and when et spoke with jason
after zoe got the role as catwoman in
the new batman film he had this sweet
reaction she's going to be huge yeah
she's beautiful she's talented it's just
going to be
she's going to kill it and people are
going to be
like well
welcome to the team baby but when it
comes to his two younger kids the sweet
girl star told et last august why he's
not so sure about them getting into the
family business
you and your lovely wife some incredible
acting jeans could you put them in one
of your movies one day would you say oh
man one of them wants to do it i'm not a
fan and i don't want
them them too but uh
i don't know i'll try with my i'll try
my damn just to keep them out of it
but you don't you love it
i love storytelling i love back to
filmmaking so i mean i like you know
directing and filmmaking but
um i just
i want them to you know go for other
things you know i want them to really to
go for other things and if they want to
maybe
but i i don't want them to get into
acting it's very hard it's very hard
it's very hard on people and uh
you know i don't want them to have that
kind of pressure i'm tough enough to
handle it but i wouldn't want to put
someone i love
into that well it sounds like you might
be doing more producing and directing
one day do you want to head in that
direction yeah well i've been directing
for a while now so it's been uh it's
been a passion that you know i'd rather
see the full project than just being the
one piece of it but
it's nice also just being the actor so
i'm happy i can be full
[Music]